good morning believe nation today's
message is think about what's next
overuse sundar Pichai from our
perspective and I think it's true for
technology in particular you know the
world keeps changing as I said earlier
so in a big part of what I focus on at
any given time is you know making sure
we are innovating and building products
for the future you know it's just got to
be a normal course of how you think and
so you know we're constantly thinking
about what to do next so you know
android is very popular people are using
smartphones but you know I always say
don't think about what is the next
version of how people use computing
right and so we are thinking about you
know things like virtual reality or
augmented reality so these are all new
areas but we are constantly thinking
about it and so you have to do that on a
constant basis to push forward I think
his entrepreneurs generally we're good
at thinking about what's next it's why
we started our businesses it's you know
we're unhappy with the job we're at or
the state of the world and we want to go
and create something new and different
and amazing and so especially the early
stages of a business I think
entrepreneurs are really really good at
thinking about what's nice we're the
innovators with the entrepreneurs we're
here to solve the problems I think where
we sometimes let ourselves down is we
fall into the trap of what has worked
before and what I see over and over and
over again with a lot of entrepreneurs
is you have this new innovative idea
nobody's doing it it's great it's
amazing awesome you know you have to
make some tweaks but then you get your
customers on board you start getting
some success you start seeing some
growth and then you stopped innovating
because that success that you've had now
puts you in a box and you think I have
to keep doing the same thing I've had
these customers I have to keep doing the
same thing over and over and over again
so that I keep these guys happy and you
stop coming up with new stuff and you
find it so many times with entrepreneurs
that they get bored with their business
they get bored because they put
themselves in a box you put yourself in
a box if this is if I'm talking to you
right now you put yourself in a box
because you keep doing the same thing
you let that pass success hold you back
from doing
new and innovative things if i look at
my channel is an example my youtube
channel we've had a lot of success
especially the past couple of years it's
come from two things it's come from me
constantly innovating continue to come
up with new ideas new series new promos
some of them work some of them don't
some of the most success that we've had
with our recent videos have come from
new series that didn't exist six months
ago and here they are having amazing
success and blossoming and I've had a
ton of failures that some of you guys
may notice and most you probably won't
even notice like we did one or two
videos as a trial and maybe didn't work
out but it's constantly testing and so
that new innovation even even on our top
Penn series and our older series that
have had success within them tweaking
them trying new things playing around
with them because it's better for you
guys and it's better for me and the
second part of it is this channels had
success because of my enthusiasm my
enthusiasm is constantly at a high
because I love the work that I'm
creating because I'm constantly
innovating well your notice if you feel
like you're chopped in a box and just
doing the same thing over and over and
over again Your Enthusiasm levels are
going to drop you're not renew you meant
to be out create a new stuff your
pioneer you're not some best job person
who has to do the same thing repeatedly
day in day out right if that's you
you're going to lose your enthusiasm
you're going to lose your drive we're
going to get bored of your business
you're going to want to go off you do
something else and so you need to factor
in the time to constantly have something
new that you're working on that maybe
works out maybe doesn't work out that's
part of the game but if you stop
innovating and stop thinking about what
the next thing is your business is going
to suffer maybe not today but in the
really near future because you're going
to get bored and you're going to stop
coming up with new ideas as well so the
question of the day today is have you
ever been bored in your business and why
leave in the comments below I'm going to
join in the discussion finally want to
give a quick shout it to himanshu premye
thank you so much for buying a copy of
my book it really really really means a
lot to me those you watching you want
your chance at a shadow in the future
video make sure to pick up a copy of the
book and email in your receipt so when
you keep track and send you
the bonuses to thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and they'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot events
beso oh wait its prey so give me go